foreign
[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Friday March 10th I'm Zoe Thomas for The
Wall Street Journal
the Holy Grail of energy transmission is
a superconductor something that
transfers energy without giving away any
in the form of heat but most
superconductors are wildly impractical
because they typically only work under
extreme cold or pressure
researchers at the University of
Rochester think they might have a
solution and this technology could
eventually have a huge impact on how we
consume energy here to talk through what
they found and why it matters is our
science reporter Island Woodward hi
Island thanks for joining us again hi
thanks so much for having me again so
Island what's different about the
conductors the research team in
Rochester discovered basically ever
since the first superconductor was
discovered in 1911. researchers have
been trying to discover
materials that are capable of
superconducting that don't need these
extreme requisite conditions and the way
they go about trying to solve that
conundrum is they try different recipes
different Atomic recipes
in the case of this new breakthrough
the superconductor recipe in question
they took hydrogen they added a little
bit of nitrogen and a rare earth
material called beautician
and basically squeezed it and heated it
to see what happens and then once they
had created this new material they
dialed back the pressure and they amped
up the temperature to see if it could
still be a superconductor even when it
wasn't really cold or wasn't under
extreme pressure so new material that
they've discovered it doesn't need to be
super cooled it doesn't need to be super
pressurized that's what you're telling
us correct it does operate at room
temperature 69 degrees Fahrenheit and
then in terms of pressure
the caveat here is it works at a much
lower pressure than other
superconducting materials it works at
000 pounds per square inch of pressure
we actually experience 15 pounds per
square inch at sea level so we're not
quite at ambient pressure yet but the
special thing about getting the
superconductor into this 145 000 pounds
per square inch range is that there are
techniques and instruments that
engineers and material scientists can
use to achieve those pressures without
needing super expensive specialized
equipment so those pressures are used in
chip manufacturing and synthesizing
diamonds for example so the way an
outside expert explained it to me is
that this new discovery sort of brings
the superconductor into a range where
Engineers can jump on it and make
something commercially viable out of it
it's much
sure to have energy conducted this way
than through the conductive materials we
use at the moment
so the thing I think a conductive
materials we use at the moment is as you
mentioned there's always a loss in the
transfer and distribution
as he typically and the thing about
superconductors is that you don't see
that loss it is perfect efficiency but
right now the scales are sort of
unbalanced because you have to maintain
these extreme conditions that enable the
superconducting material to work so in
the case of the superconducting magnets
in an MRI machine for example they need
liquid helium to cool down those magnets
in order for them to work in order for
them to sort of yield that beneficial
lossless
electric current transfer and so in
order to get those benefits you have to
then pay the piper you have to
facilitate those extreme conditions and
if we were able to swap in a
superconductor that worked at room
temperature or worked at pressures that
were closer to ambient pressure it would
mean that these devices are cheaper to
make and maintain it would mean that we
could shrink them down so we could make
for example maybe smaller MRI machines
that were portable because you wouldn't
need that bulky cooling apparatus to
make the superconducting material happy
it is this something that could say help
in electrical devices that we use you
know maybe in our homes or in our
everyday lives absolutely and I think
that's really the application that maybe
first comes to mind when you chat about
superconductors is if you have them in
your handheld devices your phones and
your laptops they'll need less
electricity to run they won't lose that
energy as heat when you have your laptop
in your lap and it overheats like that
won't happen if superconducting
components are involved and the same
components could be incorporated into
electric car batteries for example or
electric planes even one of the experts
said and then the two sort of lead
scientists from this University of
Rochester group they told me that they
think we'll have devices with
superconducting components in them in
the next five years could this type of
conductor make it easier to use
renewable energy because storing that
has always been a big hurdle we can
Source any kind of energy a lot easier
but I mean people often talk about
superconductivity as maybe being a key
thing to leverage in the fight against
climate change because
a superconducting grid could store solar
or wind energy for an indefinite period
of time and then transfer it over a
large distance for example say you're in
a place like Arizona or California or
Florida where you get a lot of sun so
you have a solar grid and you collect a
lot of this energy but you can't get it
to a place far away that doesn't get as
much sun without a loss or for example
you could Bank up a lot of stored solar
or wind energy and then just store it
until you needed it in a superconducting
grid because of that idea that you can
you know this technology can help store
energy for a Perpetual period of time
what steps do they have to take to get
it out of the lab and into these
commercial products they explain it to
me as they need to get to a point where
they can create this superconducting
material either this new one that they
just announced or they're continuously
tweaking their recipes they're trying to
get closer to room temperature and zero
pressure like zero pounds per square
inch and as they go about tweaking their
methodology they have to figure out how
to make this material in bulk one of the
goals is creating like wire that's made
out of this particular new type of
superconducting material that can be
distributed they need to figure out how
to make more of it more efficiently and
cheaply
and that's probably the next step so
it's all about more efficiency more
cheaply and then eventually more energy
right they explained it as like there's
always a Holier Holy Grail
so okay something to Aspire to then
that's our science reporter Island
Woodward thanks for joining us thanks so
much for having me and that's it for
today's Tech news briefing but a quick
note on AI before we close the show we
want to hear your questions about
generative artificial intelligence AI
programs like chat GPT Microsoft's new
Bing search or mid-journey and we're
going to answer them on an upcoming
episode do you want to know more about
how these AI programs work what they're
capable of or maybe with this latest
wave of AI development could mean for
how we live our lives leave us a voice
recording with your AI question at tnb
wsj.com or leave us a voicemail on
415-439-6482 we look forward to hearing
from you
tnb's producer is Julie Chang we had
production assistants from Zoe Culkin
our supervising producer is Melanie Roy
and our executive producer is Chris
sinsley I'm your host Zoe Thomas thanks
for listening and have a great weekend
foreign
[Music]